foreign
what's up
yes hi thank you for taking my call our
pleasure how can we help
so I was going to see your show for a
while and I was starting to fade and
trying to get out of debt and doing all
that stuff and obviously I do have a
play in his car so I was thinking about
it but not willing to but then I had an
insurance problem and they realized or I
realized that I had points in my life a
lot so my insurance went up to 600
um a month plus my car know it's like
450. your insurance went up to 600 a
month
yes why
um I have five points on my license that
I didn't realize until I updated my life
and saw my insurance
okay
wow so now the penalty 35 months for it
um so I have that and then I have my car
payment which I know was kind of stupid
it was it's 450. so my idea was to get
rid of a car because my kids schools are
distance where I can walk them
um and then get an the only issue is I
work in my car I do Uber but I just feel
like it's not worth it anymore so it
would make more sense for me to get a
real job or something else I guess
um and I won't have a cargo but I have
the tea station across from my house
like right there I think you have a
great plan
I think that's a great point
I guess my question is
how what to like how to go about it I do
have
I don't know if it's
taken advantage or but I do live in like
Section 8 Housing and I have a lot of
like government assistance but I know
the goal will be to move up and away so
I do have a few options and I guess that
was my question do I lower my rent and
take two part times and then start
career searching and you know figure out
what how old are you
27 and then I have two kids I'm a single
mom of two kids
and I'm 27. hmm
okay um you got your hands full okay
listen let's back up whoa whoa whoa stop
stop stop let's back up okay one of the
you're asking really really good
questions after you got this really
Stern wake-up call from your insurance
company
uh and you're it's kind of shook you and
you're you're really re-looking
everything and that's very wise that's
very smart so the one of the things I
learned many many years ago I read a
piece of research that said that rich
people when they're making decisions
think about
how it's going to affect them 20 years
from today
poor people think about how it's going
to affect them Friday
mm-hmm and I've been both by the way
I've been the Thank God It's Friday oh
God it's Monday Barry barely hanging on
by my fingernails where you are right
now
and so what I learned to do is I said if
I want to be rich people rich people
don't make decisions because that way
because they're rich they're rich
because they make decisions that way and
so what we want to do is increase the
planning window and so when I run into
someone in your case and you're a very
inspiring young woman I think you're
going to really be somebody someday
I want to ask myself 10 years from today
where do I want to be and which of these
decisions take me there
because if you're not careful you make
short-term decisions which keep you in a
short-term situation if you make
long-term decisions let me tell you what
almost always happens they're almost
always painful now and awesome later
short-term decisions are almost always
awesome right now but painful later
because I'm stuck
does that make sense to you
yes so what's the best career path for
you that makes you
have an amazing life 20 years from today
and what are the steps along that ladder
that are there and what's the first step
of that even if it's a a painful step or
something you don't want to do right now
and it feels icky right now but by you
know by uh by summer we'll start to see
the light a little bit and then by the
next summer really start to see the
light a little bit and so on and so you
know an example of that is Uber is a is
a is a valid good side hustle it's not a
real good long-term career play agreed
uh yes I finally agree with that yeah so
I mean even if your car even if your car
insurance hadn't gone up you don't want
to be if you're 27 now you don't want to
be a 57 year old Uber driver
in in flying cars or whatever right but
I mean it's that that's not a good
long-term place so what is our long-term
play what do we want to be and what are
the steps to get there what must be true
about you and your life that's not true
about you and your life today to get you
there and when Sharon and I went broke
and lost everything and we had a little
baby and a toddler and we were so scared
we couldn't breathe and the electricity
got cut off and the water got cut off
because I didn't pay the bill because I
didn't mean money I had to stop and
think hey I got to get those turned back
on but B what do I do so that I'm never
here again
and I started asking myself those
questions and that's how a lot of the
principles on this show were born so
we've got three issues on the table
today we need to make decisions about
with a long-term mindset career housing
and transportation
yes okay long term riding the Subway or
the bus is not going to make you wealthy
that's right
short term it might enable you to save
up and pay cash for a two thousand
dollar car and your insurance won't be
much on a two thousand dollar car
okay so maybe we do that for a little
while long term living in subsidized
housing obviously is not going to make
you wealthy
but short term it might give you the
footing to take some steps towards
getting out right
yes so we start setting some dates and
stuff in front of us of where we're
going to go from there yeah you know
jerixa the situation that you're in I I
relate to in some ways and there's
something about kind of feeling rock
bottom right you feel like you're at the
bottom but now the way to go is up right
there you know necessity truly is the
mother of invention and sit down like
Dave said and really start looking
through okay what can I do I want to
give you uh Ken Coleman's uh paycheck to
purpose and start thinking through all
right what can I do with myself
career-wise what will that look like
with child care and really start putting
this I don't want it floating around in
your mind I want you writing these
things down on paper and creating a
clear Plan before I let you go let me
right quick I'm gonna jump in on you
Jade I'm gonna give you so much stuff
it's going to be unbelievable because I
think you're awesome and I want you to
go do everything we tell you to do I'm
going to put you in Financial Peace
University we're going to sign you up
for Ken Coleman's career assessment
we're going to send you his book on
payche the purpose that Jade was talking
about I'm going to send you my book a
Total Money Makeover I want you to work
six extra jobs I want you to stay in
that place right now and get you a two
thousand dollar car by one year from
today I want you out of there and I want
you in a decent full-time job taking you
towards your career your short-term
steps to get to your long-term goals so
27 year old single mom with two kids 52
percent of the single moms in America
live below the poverty level and she's
probably right close
yeah and the
the reason I just dumped all this stuff
on her is it's my best shot to help her
uh and so
the interesting thing is is that um
over 30 years of doing this I have met
I'm not exaggerating when I say
thousands of people who have
taken basic financial principles like
we're talking about looking long term
saving money
uh not because when you look short term
you take out a big car payment because
the car smells nice right when you I
mean she's living in subsidized housing
as a 400 car payment see that's 450.
that's what keeps you there yeah and so
uh
but but the opposite of that is what we
started describing and what she had
already come to in her own wisdom uh but
but
the story for you in America is that you
can go from there to millionaire
your bad break can become Your Big Break
and
it is about applying the principles and
thinking long term and
um
it's like a buddy of mine who who grew
up in a really rough neighborhood he's
uh said it's easier to get out of the
hood and just get the hood out of you
uh that real talk you know and I it's
it's easier to get out of the old
neighborhood whatever your old
neighborhood is because how many times
have any of you out there listening to
me have heard or even said these words
uh
People Like Us
yes Dave dot dot dot the first time I
ever ran into it and I thought it was so
humorous because I was I'm of course a
southern redneck hillbilly right yeah
yep and uh
about as white as white can be right and
so I I thought redneck people like me
were the only ones that did stupid butt
stuff with car payments so I I you know
start to get a little bit of traction
and people are inviting me to speak and
I end up in New York City speaking this
group of people there there was about a
thousand people in the audience and it
was pretty much the United Nations yeah
I mean there's every color every stripe
every background every uh uh accent
except mine yeah in in the audience
right and so I was pretty entertaining
to them with my hillbilly accent right
but uh when I got off the stage and
started signing I was cracking up
because this lady comes up to me and she
goes but you don't understand
I'm Puerto Rican and I'm like I'm sorry
I don't know what that means I mean I
know what a Puerto Rican is but I don't
know what you're talking about she goes
all Puerto Ricans have to have a big car
payment no we have to have a nice car
and I'm like darling that's not a Puerto
Rican disease that's a human disease
I mean people like us I'm probably
getting ready to get myself canceled but
I hear it all the time Jade the system
is set up for people like us to feel
yeah I hear it all the time and it does
I got to tell you that is not an
African-American thing that's not a
Puerto Rican thing that is not even a
redneck white guy thing I mean it's
because I heard that you know the little
man can't get ahead people like us but
the corporations I I got a relative to
the corporations the corporations I'm
like what are you even talking about
look look look yes there are things
there are obstacles to overcome for
anybody for anybody their sexism there's
racism there's ageism there's all these
things but you're more limited by your
own mindset than you are limited by
anything systemic because it's like what
you said I can get out of the hood but I
didn't get the hood out of me all right
you know those are the things that's a
mindset but the thing I was thinking
about with her is she can do this she
can I the problem is I believe she can
do it maybe more than she does right now
and that's because she's not got anybody
around her going you can do this that's
right she's not hanging out with people
that are doing it she doesn't have a
community around her going lifting her
arms up saying you got this you got this
you got this so we tried in just a
moment there to be your community and
love her and jump a bunch of things on
her but guys
you can do this she is going to have to
be very intentional about changing her
own mind and because we we poured it
into her but she's got to keep filling
her mind with I can do this I can
overcome this I can earn money I can get
out I'm so
it's for me it is for me Financial Peace
is for me too not just the people on TV
not just the Joneses not just the folks
over there financial pieces for you
being debt free is for you not just
those folks over there so I hope she
believes that there are idiots that will
hold you back
for some stereotypical reason
um again racism is real uh sexism is
real uh regionalism
I I have people that wouldn't put me on
the radio because they thought with a
Southern accent I must be broadcasting
from a double wide not wearing shoes
but that doesn't mean that that's true
it just means that's an ignorant person
a hundred percent of racists are
ignorant people 100 of sexist or
ignorant people and you know that's
ridiculous uh and so you can't let
ignorant people make your decisions for
you and set up your the boundaries by
which you run your life and so it just I
you know
the first thing I did was when I was a
kid I got indoctrinated my parents got
in the real estate business with the
Positive Thinking movement and then I
kind of got uh that's just overdone and
it is overdone yeah uh sometimes but I
mean you can't positive think your way
into anything but you can't negative
think your way into anything right right
you can't apologize to think your way
into everything but you can't negative
think your way into anything that's good
David and you can you got to have new
information continuing to do the same
thing over and over again expecting a
different result and blaming it on
someone else is part of what you're
doing yeah is the definition of insanity
so this that's why we get so angry
around here and passionate about victim
thinking she didn't have Victory she did
not no she I mean she called scratching
and clawing trying to figure out a way
yeah but
some people look at her situation go
well the problem is not her the problem
is the systemic problems in the economy
and the the the whole back of a lady
like that yeah they're there they're
there but you've heard me say it Dave
she can do it you can't blame your way
to a better life those are all things
that you can blame that'll tweet but at
the end of the day you can build your
way to a better life you can believe
your way you can behave your way you
cannot blame your way and I love that
she called here because she's tired she
wants to do something different and she
can so the reason I'm going off on the
soapbox is for all of you that are
listening you actually can help people
and you don't help them by giving them a
government program
you help them by showing them the way
out and putting your arm around them and
walking with them on their way out yep
and so those of you that are using our
materials in uh halfway houses where
people are working their way out of
prison those of you that are using our
materials in domestic violence housing
that are letting those ladies get a new
life after they decided after they've
got in a situation where they're no
longer a punching bag those of you that
are using our materials in uh subsidized
housing situations or in lower income
whatever you want to call it situations
homeless shelters a lot of them we send
them stuff all the time those of you
that are doing that it works
thank you
you are the answer to these peoples to
folks in that situation
that the reason I'm not broke anymore is
because people love me enough to put
their arm around me and show me a
different way I didn't figure it all out
in my own head I know that's right I'm
here because y'all came alongside me
without even knowing you without even
knowing me it's it it's the material
like he said if you if you are putting
this message out there you have no idea
uh the domino effect that you're
creating so there's a power to hope that
supersedes
ignorant people
that are in ISM if you're an ism you're
an ignorant person
and you're in the way
and so if you're engaging in an ism
that's your problem yeah and there's the
power that supersedes that is Hope and
that's not some kind of false Panacea
positive thinking way the truth is when
you believe that you can go do stuff so
you go do it that's when you get there
but when you believe you can't do it
then you don't go do it and and so when
someone says well it's a systemic I want
to smack them because you're a hope
stealer
when you do that you're a hope stealer
when you allow someone to blame
something on someone else instead of
going after the dad blame solution grab
it by the throat yes it's yours oh God
she's inspiring to me I love it she's
gonna be awesome hey we need to follow
up with her I already got her email Dave
I'm already on it you're on it all right
you step ahead of me this is the Ramsay
show